[Music]
and we're live everyone welcome to
another episode of rent cafe episode 27
I believe I'm Ana Mack here for anime
offer and this is a special special
episode everybody in this one we're
going to finally determine once and for
all definitively no questions anymore
which is the better iconic Shonen anime
Naruto or one piece this is it this is
the one now joining me today we have up
our for the first time let me just see
I'm getting some feedback here think I
have win multiple windows open or
something okay there we go
for the first time this week we have
miss art joining us to represent the
Naruto side along with our boy Lotus who
has joined us in the past so miss art
I'll start with you please introduce
yourself to the people Oh awesome well
first of all thank you so much for
inviting me to grant cafe I appreciate
it
our pleasure thanks for accommodating me
in your schedule as well as I was gone
last week stuff that was very nice um
yeah so I'm miss art I have a channel on
YouTube if you look me up in my SSA RT
you will see that my channel is
predominantly about Naruto and has been
for about five or six years now I can't
believe I've been talking about Naruto
that long but I definitely been a fan
for a lot longer so I'm happy to
participate and defend marucho's honor
in this debate bring it excellent
pleasure to have you and by the way
everyone's links are in the description
if you want to directly go to their
channel you don't even have to search
them just click to this link in the
description and yes so hopefully this
debate you know we're gonna have a
friendly but passionate debate no one
has to get hurt friendly you don't have
the other enemy sucks but we are gonna
be arguing that uh you know the each
sides gonna be arguing their points it's
not gonna be like when me and Briggs
were I'm Tony the black right guys
channel arguing that
Amelia's best girl and screw Ram it's
fine to be one of those once
who's grabbed by the wait Briggs good
job on winning that debate with me this
one four is going to be a little more
you know friendly friendly banter style
I think but I don't know I feel like
lotuses Briggs might go at each other
I feel like this art and two spooky are
really nice but Lotus and Briggs they
might glide each other Briggs a monopod
big fella and when we're since we're
speaking of Lotus lotus what's up
welcome back to Ranke fan you are also
going to be representing Naruto he is
really thank you for having me back on
podcast again it's always a pleasure to
be around all you lovely people here
today but yeah my name is Lotus you can
check me out over on my channel the nerd
corner corner and I haven't actually
uploaded in a couple of weeks that kind
of it's lacking on my game but uh I just
haven't been satisfied with the quality
of my videos so I'm regrouping myself
free collecting and I'll be back in the
game very soon but uh yeah over on my
channel I do a lot of manga related
content discussions tags I've also been
doing a lot of gaming content mainly
with Dragon Ball universe too since that
is a popular anime game aside right now
but with the release of injustice to or
might be doing some content on that in
the near future because I'm having a lot
of fun with that game right now but yeah
so basically a lot of anime manga
related content over on my channel as
well as gaming which is mostly anime
gaming but you might see how the
fighting games on there too so uh yeah
nice and again pleasure having you back
and as a fan fellow fan of fooly cooly
always love talking to you loser you're
a good guy great guy and now we have
brigs mr. makes noise with his
microphone when he's not on Briggs from
all-day anime what's up bro not me yeah
also referred to as the Lumpy's guy
apparently I know what guy Korn otoni
right hello hello I'm excited for this
one-piece debate just happen to be
wearing the 1p shirt works out that way
just so happening ready feel I'm like
blown the odds
oh my channel yeah all the anime I do
faction things I explain stuff all the
anime all the animu he does things and
stuff good thing girl stuff go check
about nice yeah and by the way last but
not least we got our boy 2spooky who
enjoys both Naruto and one piece but he
is first and foremost a one piece
fanboy and he will admit that I think
what's up spooky uh that is correct
thank you once again for having me on
mr. Anna Mack and yes I'm a huge fan of
both Naruto and one piece but personally
I feel that one piece is the superior
series which is why I'm going to be
siding with it today but my channel is
it's kind of a [ __ ] to be honest
but it's mainly based around facts and
it's not anime exclusive but the
majority of my content is anime related
so yeah yeah absolutely
check out all these lovely people's
channels guys I was personally
influenced by all of them in some ways
spooky knows in particular that me and
goes and we're influenced with some ways
fact videos the fact videos because he
works so much and so hard on them and
puts in such effort that we appreciate
other we made a few of those videos we
definitely appreciate even more how much
you work you put into it and of course
Briggs has been doing a great job on his
channel decently as well so yeah great
people to hang out with great youtubers
overall here on rant cafe this is why we
are according to ANBU the greatest
podcast of all time that's all yeah I
like to quote other people so it's not
me you know I'm humble but it's like
it's the people who say that this is the
greatest podcast alright way better
deafening giggle was doing before you
you know but but okay okay there was a
lot of hype for this debate even last
week it was a complete different we
talked about anime conventions because
enemy North is this weekend and Briggs
I'm going to be meeting Briggs for the
first time IRL including panel as well
makkal not vector Maximus and a bunch of
people there this weekend but yeah
people were even last week there were
not two versus one piece they were going
at it so I'm really looking forward to
seeing how the chat is gonna be reacting
to this and however how everyone here is
going to be reacting and it's in the
chat if you have certain questions and
points you want to raise be sure to do
it in the chat I will be moderating
because I personally haven't watched
much of or really care for either of
these shows I'm sorry guys
yes but in that sense it means I really
have zero bias
zero bias in in this topic Zoila a
neutral candidate moderator yeah I'm
like that you know
conceited snob guy who's like Oh
mainstream Shonen know a man I only
watch her go proxy and [ __ ] serial
experiments lain man
yeah fooly cooly always hahaha
how's the issue well so who wants to
start off kind of just sort of
introductory marks
why you love your show and why you feel
like it's the stronger show I will open
the floor whoever wants to start how
happen personally you know I got I got I
got some things I want to get off my
chest so I would really call myself a
1-piece hater although I've been called
one by one piece fans but one of my
biggest brush with the show is that it
just starts off really really slow and I
think this is something that even most
one piece fans will agree with some of
the more level-headed ones um and it's
just I've personally never been able to
get to the series for that exact reason
when it comes to both the anime and the
manga I've never made it very far in the
anime at all probably not past the first
in episodes because it's something that
never interests me when I was younger or
even now that I hold her but what's the
manga people always say that oh it gets
really really good after this part they
always say like you know at this arc or
this part after this many chapters one
starts to get really really good and
even if that's the case I don't feel
like that justifies how much work in
time you have to put into a street in
order for it to become enjoyable because
in my personal experience I read the
first hundred or so chapters it was at
least a hundred chapters and I thought
it was so-so you know it was okay it
wasn't great it wasn't horrible but it
was really my cup of tea I'm not a big
fan of pirates I wasn't really
investigating the characters I'm also
not a huge fan of Metro's art stuff but
you know that's the subjective thing we
all see art differently we'll have own
perspective on that but I don't feel
like saying that you have to get past
like the first two to three hundred
chapters of a series and then it gets
like it becomes the greatest thing of
all time justifies that because there
are so many series out there in my
opinion that are phenomenal and they are
only about a hundred chapters like I
think that that was like one hundred
twelve chapters total and it's you know
obviously hailed as one of the greatest
series of all time it's a classic people
love Death Note and that's always one of
the comparisons that I make because it's
short sweet to the point it's an amazing
story from start to finish you don't
have to wade through the the lesser part
of
series in order to get to the good part
but this is how I feel
yes that's a good point that Lotus you
make because yes some people say oh well
you haven't you know read the manga if
you watch an anime you're like well you
haven't read the manga well I mean they
should stand on its own but also with a
manga if it doesn't draw you in within
the first 100 chapters like what do we
you know what are we doing here so it's
absolute legitimate to say this is not a
good or my favorite show or manga
because I couldn't get into it even
though you haven't you know read the
whole thing if you give another chance
and I think over a hundred chapters is
definitely giving it a chance so do we
have a rebuttal from the other side I
will either of you lovely gentlemen I
look like you wanted to jump in break so
go ahead yeah I'll jump in you could add
something too if you want um basically
what I'm for me though um I could agree
great shows should not take that amount
of time in my opinion I very much
enjoyed the brought ta arc and the are
long arc which were pretty early fights
a one-piece takes about 25 episodes to
like get going which is not a solid
defense but to counter in terms of
Naruto I enjoyed the first 60 episodes
of Naruto or like however many chapters
that equates to and then it was at that
point where it's like it started strong
and I've got so over it going in like -
even towards like the end of Shippuden
when it was all over the place with the
war so forth grammar yes yeah I feel
like Naruto had a strong start with that
it's like it just wasn't I say it wasn't
meant to be a long-running story and
didn't complete Wow well one piece on
the other hand it's all about the
journey I feel like it is one of the
only shown in that's meant to be a
long-running like shown in it because
oda fleshed out his world in a way where
it's like people say like it didn't
start to a hundred chapters that's when
they enter the grand line and
essentially so like luffy wants to be
the prior king nami wants to like nah
let's go draw the entire world
the Soraa wants to be the greatest
swordsman they all have these
over-the-top dreams and to achieve it
they essentially have to travel the
entire world so it makes sense for it to
be so long and continue going from
island to island and you understand that
well I think Naruto was kind of all over
the place and
it had a strong start but it lost me
along the way that's I don't we do I
want to say because I've heard this
point before again I'm not an expert on
the subject
however I've heard a lot of people say
who are Naruto fans that not just art is
strong but then it got kind of
ridiculous after the ship within era so
to speak and Miss art you actually uh
you've been you've been uh handling art
on each other for long time and now
you're also look making videos about
boruto right so you know your stuff I do
I'd like to say I know my stuff and I've
experienced journey of Naruto's story
basically I was it was coming out I
think I started reading the manga back
in 2004 so it was pretty easy to catch
back up and I took a little break and
then I jump back into it so I have I can
say I have the perspective of traveling
through the story as it was coming out
for many years so at least from my
perspective I can bring that opinion to
the table and it seems like it's been a
long time in a good way but I don't want
to interrupt the point you might be
trying to make no I was actually going
to ask you to kind of counterbalance
this point that says the Naruto kind of
the rails and should not have been going
out for this long what is your take on
this do and a lot of people have also
said that boruto is unnecessary right
that it's just kind of trying to make
money from this of course we know how
dragged down one piece has been so
that's not really a criticism that one
piece fans can level at boruto but I
wanted to ask you in general yeah what
second general what are your thoughts is
how would you counter this type of art
because you clearly do still enjoy
Naruto boruto oh definitely I don't
think anybody can argue right now that
one piece is the king of content that
goes on and on and on and some I think
will find that that's a good thing
because there is a lot of material to
explore as others we're saying um but on
the flip side that does make it very
difficult for newbies to get into one
piece and that is something that I have
I want to say against cuz like I don't
want to hate on one piece I definitely
prefer not at oh I don't want to hate on
it but that is a huge barrier like there
is so much whereas Naruto
it basically wrung out all that all the
action all the character development it
could within a story that ended that's
the positive thing is that Naruto as a
series completed its arc and if you want
to go in and enjoy it you can and so
some people at least in terms of the
manga because we all know that one piece
anime and one piece not a turd Naruto a
both have tons of filler especially not
a Cho so I'm gonna focus story was manga
so we know the manga you know there are
aspects of Naruto I will admit that they
did stretch things out a bit and even
some areas I would have liked to see
things go longer so the storytelling
isn't perfect but it's overall really
enjoyable because each chapter and each
arc would up the ante things would get
more intense especially as the final war
went on again not perfect storytelling
but definitely enjoyable storytelling
and there was a reason why when Naruto
chapters were coming out that the whole
anime community would just be on fire it
would be lit I kind of missed that
nowadays so that is at least one big
positive thing I can say though is that
I don't think it got too stretched out I
think it got all the attention they can
give it without being super redundant
without being super dumb and they ended
it it completed but as we know naruto is
one of the most successful franchises
outside of japan so it is a cash cow no
matter what they do as Naruto fans are
going to eat it up so it made total
sense that they continued on with the
next generation with boruto and I think
they're actually pretty doing a pretty
decent job overall so I'm excited to see
things continue and I don't think
they're like rehashing I'm sure they're
trying to make money but so far
everything's been feeling relatively
fresh and being doing relatively good so
I think that arguments kind of moot I
think the fact that one piece is going
and going and going is eventually going
to become a negative because more fans
cannot enjoy it new fans cannot enjoy it
quite as easily so those are my thoughts
thank you thank you mister and I think
that's a really good point too because
me personally the reason I never started
one piece was that I was like there's no
way you know there's no way I can get
into it now it's gone on for way too
long there's no way I can catch up I
can't commit not much and I've thought
good brings about this before so yeah I
think that's a very solid point and if
there's a border to at least they didn't
wait like Dragonball Z like how many
years to come up with a sequel so at
least there's some kind of continuous
continuation there and I so I definitely
understand that and also in terms of
Briggs point about one piece being you
know they go to different islands so
there's a lot of stuff to explore I mean
you could say the same thing about
Pokemon they go to different regions
they explore the finality but that
doesn't mean that it's necessarily a
good thing right
that doesn't mean that the plot
progresses that it's you know quality
show so I just want to put that out
there the saying I will give it I will
get to 2spooky now because I think it's
his turn to say why he loves one piece
and what he thinks one piece has to
offer that other anime including Naruto
do not oh man
the pressures on well before that while
I have it in my mind I just kind of want
to rebuttal something or what Lotus said
earlier so he was saying how one piece
you know it had a very slow start very
hard to get into so to bring another
anime into this like you brought up a
second ago the beginning of one piece
reminds me a lot of what Dragonball
started out as like Dragonball it wasn't
meant to be a long-running series and I
feel like a lot of the things in the
original Dragonball are reminiscent in
one piece it starts out the main
character he's extremely overpowered and
like everyone who opposes him just gets
rekt immediately and along the way he
just keeps running into more and more
people like in Dragon Ball
Goku runs into Bulma and then eventually
they get to Yamcha and krillen
and blah blah whereas in one piece he's
the captain and he wants to become the
pirate
so he has to find his crew members one
by one and you can't just give him a
crew of people with no meaning you have
to develop these characters along the
way so you have to give them each their
own story which yeah the beginning of
one piece does kind of start out slowly
but for me personally it didn't feel
that slow I mean I guess that's kind of
subjective okay that's a fair point
yeah it depends too because some people
will say that mushishi for example is
slow not much happens you know it's very
calm over show and that's boring to them
whereas I personally love mushishi I
feel like it's almost like a meditative
experience to watch a show like that so
you're right about the subjectivity of
these sort of perceptions and by the way
there's a lot of tension in the chat I
see whenever someone's talking they're
like you get a Miss art you tell them
and then someone else I go through key
to show you guys so I like it I like the
tension I like it's uh it's cool it's
cool there's a lot of no positive
pressure in the air but yeah I
definitely think that this is this
debate is off to a good start let me see
if we have something in the chat
interesting so far before we continue we
had a few people talking about the slow
starts we had a few people talking about
I think Josh Daphne said that he started
one piece in March and he is now on
Episode 443 or something so I guess that
in itself
his commitment there seems to boil well
for the show that he actually got into
it that much well the audience so so
religiously the other thing about one
piece is because you have to develop
these characters so that they can become
a member of the crew because really the
first goal in one piece is to basically
get his crew together so that he can
eventually sail to the Grand Line sail
to the new world become the Pirate King
oh I lost my train of thought give me a
second sorry would you say you lost your
train of thought like Naruto and one
piece seem to lose their train of
thought for chapters on end and that's
why they go on so long
go ahead okay so basically for Dragon
Ball Z for instance it kind of lost a
comet-like it lost the goal of the
series like I'd say after I'd say around
when it became to Dragon Ball Z really
because Kishu I would agree Toriyama and
then yeah
Toriyama sorry and then the majin buu
art to me it just kind of all felt like
filler like you could just tell that he
wanted to be done whereas with one piece
I feel like the goal of the series at
first was to develop all these different
crew members but at the same time
prevent or provide some sort of conflict
for everybody so that the story was
still interesting whereas after all
these crew members are established and
everything's caught up then the goal of
the series becomes venturing to become
the Pirate King
and all the conflicts that come along
with that which is why I feel like it
works as a long-running series alright
and I think that's something positive
you can say about Naruto on the flip
side is that Naruto starts out with one
goal which we all know is to become the
Hokage and by the end of it spoiler
alert he becomes the Hokage so I think
that's something really positive you
could say but one problem with Naruto is
I feel that it doesn't really flush out
any side characters in the same way
because with one piece every single
member of the straw hats has their own
goal that they want to accomplish on
this journey to the one piece basically
whereas with Naruto like he wants to
become the Hokage but you don't really
hear the same thing from anybody else
like you hear a couple people during the
like the final battle where they're like
oh yeah I want to be Hokage too but we
all know that's not ohs goal what are
their goals
we don't know and a lot of something
accomplished it that is something that I
would give to one piece that there are
several characters in that story that do
have their own clear set goals in mind
even though they are tagging along with
Luffy and they're all helping him out
release his crew they're helping him out
to achieve his goal
they'll have done personal goals whereas
in art so I guess you could say that
that is the case where there's only very
few characters that have a goal like
Sasuke has his goal you know wanting to
kill his brother restore his clan and
then of course his sights get shifted as
a sword progresses
he catches on to do information and
learns new stories where and not so has
his goal of course becoming Hokage
becoming a respected shinobi and I
wouldn't say that the tracks from the
character development of side characters
because there are several characters who
I still do develop a lot you have the
table art where there's amazing
development in that story and then you
have Sasuke and and anyone from the
Uchiha clan honestly and then all of
Naruto's villains because he's one of
those characters that give you a good
old-fashioned pep talk and then we're
gonna become pals and then so I do feel
like there is several characters with
development but that is something I will
give to one piece' edges it out that
there's just more than just the main
character has a clear set goal in mind
um one thing what I had one day I want
to add if you guys keep on saying like
the whole goal is to become like the
Hokage for Naruto because spooky said
that the Dragon Ball Z lost like their
what the goal of the series well for me
was always like he only wanted to become
the Hokage so he'd get people to accept
him he was an outcast of the village
everyone hated him for having the nine
tails Fox in him and he achieved she
being accepted by everyone by the
painter by the beginning of Shippuden
like ninety episode him to ship it in
and it was like another 300 episodes
later it was like the point of the
series was he wanted to become a Hawkeye
so he'd be accepted and then he ended up
getting accepted way earlier and they
kind of like this dragged on because
like why 45% filler and I think it just
became a money thing afterwards not you
to feel I give a cash grab after the
paint art yeah I mean that's that's a
legitimate argument because that's
something that I've seen a lot of people
say even within the narco community is
that the the pain arc is the best arc in
art so at least in the Shippuden part I
favor
I agree a there's a lot of people feel
like that Naruto became the hero he
saved the world that he saved the
village and everything so it probably
could have ended there
I would agree for the most part except
that we still had unresolved issues
elsewhere even though nard so pretty
much achieved the the major part of his
goal which is becoming accepted and
being loved by one of his village you
still have characters like Sasuke for
example who's damn near the main
character himself a very prominent
character in the series that has all
these unresolved issues and aspirations
at a whole storyline that's practically
a separate manga and it's tough with him
going on in the background so and he
I'll bring up Sasuke a lot probably
because he's the most other prominent
character in the story besides in art so
but I feel like he was such a major
later that people would have had so many
questions that you just couldn't have
ended it there and that's what I would
say so why I continued to go on after
that art and then if as you continue the
series you have to have other things
going on as well so it just kept
progressing and progressing so while I
would say that to some people it does
probably seem like a cash-strapped I
feel like there were legitimate reasons
to continue it after that point even
though not so pretty much accomplished a
major part of his goal well-argued good
you have Lotus thank you a little bit
good work good work
let me bring a counterpoint against one
piece brought up in the chat and by the
way um not too fired up says that he is
team Naruto but he's also rooting for
2spooky so it sounds like he's
conflicted yeah uh soul maka the big one
piece hater in the house and he says
that one piece should be condensed and
it would be more interesting look at
arcs like sky pea and dress a role so so
what do you want peace guys say to that
okay I can't say that sky Pio was my
least favorite arc because I felt that
it dragged really hard which I will
agree with you there but dressrosa on
the other hand I feel like there was
always something happening the whole
time to make it interesting so I don't
really think that needed to be condensed
at all and it also introduced a lot of
important characters and they did a
really good job with keeping all of
those side characters doing something
the whole time instead of just like
introducing them and then taking them
away that's one thing I love about one
piece say even like because there's so
many villains that were introduced in
dressrosa and they are all so fleshed
out and like to the point that I
actually started to care you the the
dude with the pacifier oh my god oh my
god like he was drawn so weirdly but
like everything had a meaning and it was
just so amazing by Greece Katya with
dragged out so of course should I have
to the to the one-piece side is like is
there a an end anywhere in sight like
because as someone from the outside
looking in it seems like one piece just
it could continue on for another decade
or two with no clear end in sight like
there's a goal there but you still don't
know how far away it is
and the reason why I asked that is
because one of my major concerns and
it's a concern that also have with
Hunter hunter which is the reason why
I'm not super overly attached that
series despite how
that actually is is that do you think
we'll ever actually see the end and I
don't want to get to more but with this
but like one of my actual concerns
louder hunter is and this is like
something that actually scares me and I
asked other fans about the series is
that do you think it'll end before
something actually happens to the Monica
because it's often brought up you know
how to gosh she is a very sickly man and
one of my own personal thoughts is maybe
something might happen to him he might
not ever
might not ever be able to finish it with
one piece being such a long-winded story
I started one of the same thing about
him because even though H Rhoda is a
very healthy man from what I can
understand he's also an extremely hard
worker which is know much stage credit
but he often seems to be to the point of
overworking himself and I don't want
this series to be something where he's
one of those Monica who over works
themselves they become exhausted and for
one reason or another he can't actually
finish the story because I think that'd
be a huge detriment to the series
despite his popularity is that you have
all these setups all these amazing goals
in mind all this character development
and then it ultimately leads nowhere
so I guess my main question is like is
there a clear end in sight and if so how
much longer you take one piece can't get
to you all four before you do eventually
reach the end I would say that the end
is definitely more of a possibility
these days like you can definitely see
where it's going because right now
without spoiling anything basically to
find the one piece they need to get to
this island called raffle which is
basically at the end of the line and to
get there you need these you need to
read these things called the road Ponte
glyphs which are in possession of the
four Janka which are basically the
strongest pirates that ever were and
basically they're getting to the point
in the story now where they're starting
to go up against these young Coe in one
way or another or they're dealing with
them in some way and they're getting to
these road poni glyphs so the only thing
that I can really see after getting that
far is some sort of art probably dealing
with the Marines and maybe one or two
small ones in there but otherwise I
can't see the series going much further
than that but of course it's one piece
so you can't be too sure and with Hunter
x Hunter I feel like Hunter x Hunter
would be a lot further along if there
wasn't so many hiatuses whereas one
piece it's like every week every other
week there's rarely ever a bigger gap
than that so it's always moving forward
so it's not like it's
far behind whereas hunter hunter they
took off like how many he took off how
many she's taken years like I think that
is actually I grasp that it's totally
like over seven years or something crazy
like that because funnily enough Hunter
hunter started like a year or two before
Naruto Naruto ended at seventy two
volumes hunter hunter is currently at 33
I think was the last one that got
released if I'm not yeah you can so I
feel like that series by itself would
you'd be able to see like some sort of
an end in sight for that one as well if
it would actually like get moving
whereas with one piece like I can start
to see the end in sight like I can see
that we're getting there whereas maybe
back in dressrosa it still seemed like
it was still so far away yeah they give
us some information now that we can
finally kind of understand what they
have to achieve to get it to get the one
piece so we have a little bit of
understanding yeah that point because it
reminds me of the Game of Thrones or
Song of Ice and Fire of dilemma and
george RR martin taking way too long to
write the series and people wondering is
he gonna like live to finish writing the
series so that is an interesting point
and someone mentioned the Chad that one
piece is a neverending story so unlike
the actual neverending story one piece
might actually be a never ending story
so that's interesting I'd also be
impaired that another point raised in
the chat uh was that Naruto doesn't seem
to have interesting side characters so
miss Hart I'd like you to address that
point what do you feel that Naruto does
have interesting side characters is this
a mischaracterization
I definitely feel it's a
mischaracterization and I'll apologize
if you hear any background noise my
landscapers decided to show up
at the best time as always it's always
when you live it recording isn't it
always there's always construction going
on or something when you're trying to
record but no I think there are a
plethora of well-developed side
characters in nod or Chow so I think
that's a I don't think that's correct at
all I mean of course you've got your
main three and then you have the Konoha
rookies all together but even beyond
that even when you go to very beginning
like Zabuza and Haku there are tons of
care
who don't even like transcend all the
different arcs or maybe the one arc
they're in but yet they become memorable
because Kishimoto does have the ability
to flesh out really believable and
relatable characters so I mean when
you're comparing it to one piece one
piece has tons of characters as well
which are all wonderfully fleshed out to
give one piece that does have wonderful
characters but Naruto has plenty of
wonderful characters too that our side
characters so yeah with each village you
can just choose that good at least two
or three from each of the villages and
you know find them enjoyable there's so
many characters there's so many I don't
know what uh I would definitely agree on
cuz I would say some of the most
prominent interesting ones to me are
definitely you know Haku and sob is that
from one of the beginning and honestly
most well-written and developed arcs in
the story of Naruto zombozo's character
development from from a villain to
whatever you want to say he became
towards the end of that arc what was
incredible to me Haku was a really
interesting character for more reasons
than one not the least of which being
what gender Haku actually is but then
you also have characters like Rock Lee
and Neji who also develop those were
both very very strong characters in a
series and if you don't think they
played major supporting roles and you
didn't find their backstories and their
origin stories very interesting I I
don't know what to tell you and then of
course there's Gaara can't forget about
guard now because not only was every
fight that Gaara had an incredible fight
and just something to really behold and
everyone knows about The Rock Lee versus
Gaara fight but also he had some amazing
character development and went through a
story that was a lot like Naruto our
main character where he was someone who
was an outcast and he wanted to be
respected and loved he didn't realize it
at first but he grew to learn that from
Naruto himself and he became this
amazing character that was you know
respected and accepted by many people
and it became to be a very prominent
powerful person in the natural world and
then you even have other characters who
didn't play as major of a role but was
so very interesting and had interesting
stories behind them like kimimaro and
then his relationship with the character
jugo that we don't even meet until
Shippuden and it's interesting to see
you know how we meet this character so
much later on in the story and then we
find out that he had this relationship
with a character that we met in the
first part so I can't speak on you know
how many characters one piece
because it is a very uh character not
character driven but it's a it's filled
with a lot of characters that all have
you know goals aspirations development
but I would say that Naruto has more
than its fair share of interesting
characters and characters with their own
developments well the thing is I
wouldn't really consider the antagonists
side character I think when I think of a
side character in Naruto at least I
think more like Naruto's classmates
that's who I think of as a side
character and for morale of a side
character that I can say in Naruto is
complete just completely thrown under
the rug yeah right there he gets to
wander to say soccer but yet is everyone
Oh shame cuz I I like Tenten like back
in the day I was like oh she seems like
a cool cake that she was pretty unique -
he did yes tossing of the bus so I'll
give I'll give Sakura some credit like
they tried like um he tried so hard to
buff up Sakura but then as soon as it
came to the final part of the war she
didn't do anything and it's it's just
baggage that moment where she
contributed in that tag team with Naruto
soccer she's like I finally caught up to
this credit everyone else the fabrics
were like no you did this exact yeah but
then she's still back there like yeah
but there's still so far ahead and she
didn't really do anything else and it
just kind of bought like I want to give
her more credit than most people do
because there are things about soccer I
do like and her fight against saucer II
one of my favorites but I'm talking more
mainly the other classmates who didn't
get very much like obviously like Rock
Lee Neji and a little bit of Hinata like
they definitely got uh what's the word
time to shine
they got favored oh I got your eyes the
other ones were thrown aside like even
like Shino just completely nothing Shino
was a character who was definitely
underexplored
alongside Kiba and many of the other
classmates I will give you that there
are there's probably an equal amount of
characters we didn't get a spotlight as
there are that that did get time to
shine so I can see where you're coming
from on that statement
agreed and I will say in general
Kishimoto special in the beginning and
through a good part of the story has
always had difficulty for some reason
like buffing up and developing female
characters in particular and as like a
female fan that's something that's
always been really obvious to me so I
think that kind of plays into why we
have characters such as Sakura who is
one of the main three characters sadly
and Tenten and other characters who they
like they do get a little brushed off to
the side and I don't know if it's just a
coincidence that they all happen to be
female that almost all the female
characters tend to get less development
um granted there are less carry male
characters in general but I do feel like
there could there was room to develop a
few more characters and in a perfect
world kishimoto would have button so I
very much in regard I'm sorry I mean I
read it going I just want to cut in a
little bit I just want to say some very
good points and I tell you guys a Lotus
and Miss are did a great job contouring
the whole side character narrative you
made some really valid points um one
thing that I was gonna say about the
whole arm now where I was where was I
going with this cuz I've been looking at
the chat oh yeah
the cartoon man has said that this is a
nice debate so far and he thinks it's
awesome he's really enjoying it so I
just want to let you guys know that
you're doing a great job as I thought
you would and people are loving it
people are enjoying it and the one thing
I miss hearted you brought up about
female characters I think is interesting
because I feel like we have that problem
in many anime like Death Note female
characters that even came out later than
Mesa was only added because there was
like no female characters right yeah we
do have that problem in anime in general
but personally as a non someone that
doesn't know much about one piece
I don't need can't even name any female
characters so it's one piece better with
developing female characters would you
guys say cuz for me as an outsider I
don't have any you know first
impressions about one piece being better
at this well I'm not this breaks yeah
mommy's backstory
it's not this is two females on the crew
Nami and Robyn currently and the one
thing I like about one piece is they've
all had like really thorough backstories
and they're all ridiculously sad for
some reason they all have to be are
heartbreaking but essentially a group of
fishermen took over Nami Island it was
holding them all hostage and basically
every month they had to pay a fee just
to be allowed to live and nummies like
stepmother was killed because you can
have enough money to pay for her kids
and so Nami took on the responsibility
of like picking up everyone everyone's
tab essentially like people set everyone
free so she became a bandit in order to
set her village free and I feel like
there aren't as many female characters
but for the ones that are relative to
this story like Nami has a really
awesome backstory
like why she become the person to
yesterday why she's such a badass and
same thing with Robyn Robyn well it's
like the last survivor that could read
those Pony glyphs on he lifts that up
2spooky was talking about and with
basically like hunted down her entire
life well even characters like Vivi
for instance they were she was a really
strong female lead even like she wasn't
part of the crew but she was basically
part of the crew during all of alabasta
and then you fast forward to dressrosa
and you have characters like baby five
who even though they're just a side
character they still get a fleshed-out
backstories that makes you feel for them
and gives them some development and
there aren't as many but there are
that's all I belong as many but like
there's still plenty of female
characters they're just not always
fleshed out but that goes for a bunch of
characters in one piece because there's
so many side characters not everyone
gets all the attention they deserve but
that doesn't mean they're not going to
get attention later because Oda has
continuously brought that characters
that you may have even forgot about and
give them what they need to be developed
so I definitely probably from from what
I know from what you just told me I gave
one PC edge but especially when it comes
to the female characters like there are
some really underdeveloped female
characters that we never really get to
see explored or shine in Naruto but what
I would say is that
nards was big as strong suits is its
mains character development and I don't
know too much about you know Luffy's
backstory or how much he's changed from
chapter 1 to chapter 80,000 or whatever
one pieces all right but uh I would say
that Naruto and I I can't really sound
like a like I'm not a fan but I'm saying
this but I feel like he has some of the
best character development of any story
I've ever read going from this guy who
is a prankster jokester he's looked down
upon in the village by everyone nobody
likes them he has absolutely no talent
for ninja skills and he becomes one of
the most powerful respected people in
the entire world so it seems like he's
someone who was very determined never
lost sight of his goal accomplished
every dream he ever had and is one of
the most web developers regardless of
anyone's thoughts on the actual plot and
storyline so I guess my question to you
now as we're talking about character
development is how much has Luffy
changed from the start of the story and
how has this development as a character
been in the story of one piece oh good
question because I know personally from
a lot of people just in my life your
friends stuff like that we're not even
huge anime fans they know Naruto of
course and they say the Naruto is an
inspirational figure to them they always
they were inspired by now - the way he
developed the way he went from as you
mentioned Lotus being disliked and an
outcast to becoming one of the most
respected people in the world so that is
a very strong point in young guys want
these guys how about Lucy because we
know that Luffy doesn't start as a
crybaby or anything that we establish
that Briggs I personally dislike crybaby
characters everyone knows that Renton
Thurston from Erica 7 is the worst
ah God but yes so Briggs a spooky what
do you say to that about Luffy's
development do you see compared to
Naruto as well as a character do you
think the Luffy has developed enough I
would say that Luffy is one of those
characters that doesn't really need to
develop too much because he already
starts out as a badass character who's
got the whole goofy shown inside to him
but at the same time he does develop
plenty over time it's usually just not
as much as you would think like one
moment that stud stood out to me even
though it wouldn't really seem like it's
much of a development was like bravest
Briggs too
talking about uh the whole fish man
situation with Nami there was one part
where Nami was on the ground bawling her
eyes out stabbing her arm where the
tattoo for our Long's crew was and Luffy
comes up and you know he's just watching
her he's not saying anything and you can
just tell you can't really understand
what's going through his head and then
Nami turns to him and she's like Luffy
help me and you know tears and
everything he just he doesn't say a word
to her and he just puts his head on her
head and goes to save the day and I feel
like that's one of those moments where
he's like trying to take in what she's
failing and it just develops him to like
push himself harder to actually bring
these people down and save the day even
though he's a pirate and he's supposed
to stand for what Pirates do which isn't
saving the day so would you say that he
develops more emotionally as a character
than others because he seems from what
I've read and seen and what I know of
like a character who was not very
socially adept or inept I forget the
proper phrasing for that but he's not
he's not very good with social like he
doesn't understand the emotions and
thoughts feelings well of the people too
well from my destiny that's another
thing because in the series they keep
talking about how old they mention it
from time to time how Luffy's greatest
weapon is his ability to bring people
over to his side mm-hm so the way I see
it is even though he doesn't like appear
emotionally uh and that the people just
kind of relate with him and they they
believe in him so they come over to his
side of things and even just development
developing him overall like I'd say
probably the biggest development with
Luffy I mean it's kind of a spoiler
alert I'll turn off your whatever if you
don't want to hear but his brother ace
he Luffy did everything he possibly
could to save him and he did save him
but then ace basically had to die saving
Luffy and Luffy just kind of went into
an emotional wreck after that and then
we had a whole time skip and I feel like
that was his biggest development
throughout the series
I I think it is not on the same level as
Naruto it's impossible Eichner I can
give that to Naruto Naruto like the main
character had to develop so much you'll
such an underdog character and came from
such a low place to the end point I just
think Luffy like like you were saying
before like everyone relates to Luke I
think Luffy is such a perfect character
for one piece I can't give him the
development that Naruto has but he's the
type of guy who's like he sees something
you think I wanted or he sees something
I'm going to do this regardless of how
impossible it is he waged war with the
entire world government because they
stole one of his friends and it's kind
of like everyone loves them and like
goes to his side and like is able to
relate to him because like no one can
else can see themselves like put
themselves in that situation for they're
like [ __ ] this guy does not care it's
perfect for someone who wants to be the
Pirate King say anything he believes in
he's going to do it regardless of like
if you have to sacrifice his own life to
say he believes it interesting is a
really interesting point because I
personally feel that you don't need to
have a complete underdog and then
develop their character completely in
order for them to be a strong character
right because I think you spoke you
raised some really good points there
about you know yeah Luffy starts off as
a badass already
but yet the fact that he then has to
face with difficult situations and kind
of evolve as a person and deal with
those challenges is still character
development even if he starts off as a
badass everyone knows that my favorite
character miss heart you might not but
my favorite of all time is coming up and
he starts off as a complete badass and
is always about us but he's still a
great inspirational amazing character
and he does feel challenged they deal
with challenges for example finding out
that his father is dead
early on in the show and that shocks and
butt for like five seconds and then he
moves on because he's like you know my
ideals and my motivation is stronger
than any challenge so I feel like it but
I like the fact I feel like a character
doesn't have to start off as completely
nothing and then build up in order for
it to be a good character but I likely
you guys the the Naruto side seated to
the one piece either one pieces better
side character development and
one piece I see that in our two-sided
Naruto has better overall development as
a character than Luffy so interesting
interesting debate here yes shout-out to
uh calming and making an appearance and
bort oh by the way low-key yesterday
yeah Freddy with the something episode
no I wasn't actually calm unit but there
was a character in yesterday's episode
aboard so that like wore a visor that
looks a lot like communist and he was
kind of like this like cool little hero
or whatever and then after board so saw
like he had like the same ride and he
was wearing it around and he's kind of
like talking and acting a little bit
like cognitive so I thought that was
kind of oh it's definitely a wink wink
nudge yes I thought it was a nice not
secure in the god I thought that was
kind of funny I thought my respected
board to just skyrocketed right let's go
check out the episode man it was pretty
funny yeah like if anyone if anyone's a
fanboy of anything I'm a huge communist
and boy forever hey I'm all like I try
to be all like you know sophisticated in
my anime analysis but then it's like
communist almost says I'm becoming like
what well is this more did you say
communist not perfect
yes it's like guys you can't you know
you can't take anime criticism
personally you know when they're
criticizing an anime or a character and
are criticizing you yeah calm you know
was what Oh dare you man that's my life
but I think this is going well guys a
lot among this debate I want to call on
people in the chat while I got a little
sidetracked with Briggs but people in
the chat give me some questions if you
have some specific questions that you
would like to ask either side like a
criticism a specific criticism not why
is Naruto sock or why is one piece so
long if you have a specific criticism
that you want to be addressed write it
in the chat I'll try to get to them by
Briggs I think the most important
question of this debate is where did you
get the sunburn bro
oh how do you know you're talking about
bruh you don't have a little Tanner a
sunburn
you've been outside Oh me not that much
I think you might be the light shine on
my forehead right now yeah I'm a fan
doing outside supposed to stay inside
you look like you have rosy cheeks so
you look like you're just either your
tanning or you're just loving life
you're just you know by this debate
that's what it is
so I've got a really subjective point I
want to bring up now this is you know
very subjective so obviously this is
just my opinion and this is something I
don't it's not like you can argue either
side this um I kind of want to talk
about because I'm such a big like
enthusiast of art now I am not at all a
fan of each rodas art style I don't want
to say it's bad but I'm not a fan of it
like I know he intentionally draws
characters to look very wacky very
out-there it's Danny very unique and
unique is something that I will credit
him for but I personally feel that
Masashi Kishimoto has a more interesting
art style I like the way he portrays
movement granted it does get very close
sometimes it's hard to make out what's
going on certain fight scenes within the
story but I feel like it's more uh not
engaging but uh it's more uh distracting
maybe not distracting I'm saying
Kishimoto is art style is like like it's
someone who's new to [ __ ] would
probably gravitate towards Naruto more
than one piece and that's just the
opinion that I have in my head because I
just feel like his art style is just so
different that it's kind of off-putting
for someone who would be new and looking
at the two of these series and saying
okay this one looks cooler like I would
think that Naruto looks like the cool
issues to me but I just want to know
what you guys thoughts are on each Rose
are like are you fans of it or no and
how do you how do you think it's changed
at all or has it in the first place
since beginning of the story because I
know that quisha motors are definitely
develops a lot as much as an art so does
himself from the beginning of the story
cuz I feel like it starts off strong by
the time you get around to like volume
four or five and especially you're
getting into like the dissolves arc like
he really finds his stride and finds
like his style it gets it becomes a
really really strong style so uh yeah
what are your thoughts on Otis artwork
yeah so question this is a question
about the artwork and how much art style
plays in your enjoyment experience of
manga and anime and unlike a book I'm
like a novel for example art style is a
major factor in this medium right so I
think this is a fair
question and either Briggs or spooky
well like you said it's definitely very
subjective but I understand where you're
coming from
for me personally art style isn't really
something that like deters me in any way
usually I find a way to enjoy it and I
find things that I like about it even if
it's not particularly a night style
particularly in our style I enjoy like
for one piece and Naruto I think they
both have their their positives and
negatives like for Naruto I feel like
Kishimoto had a lot of trouble designing
female characters and I'm pretty sure
he's said that before I would agree with
that he didnae learn how to do that
until recently yeah very recently and I
also feel like compared to one piece at
least I feel like not as many Naruto
characters are as unique because with
one piece sense it's a little bit more
on the different goofy side he can do a
lot more and make these characters a lot
more interesting and different from
every other character whereas Naruto
even though there are characters that
definitely stand out from others there
are some that look relatively similar
and they don't really stand out as much
and like you said with in the beginning
like Naruto he really started or with
kishimoto he started really gained his
art style down at a certain point with
one piece you can definitely see a
difference from the first however many
chapters until now the female characters
definitely got developed if it was well
developed yeah I basically I would say
that it just depends on what you like
because like I said with me I can find
things that I like for both I would say
I prefer Naruto's art style but I
definitely prefer the uniqueness of one
piece like ah
Naruto reminds me more of the art style
of bleach which is my favorite art style
for manga I think it's just so clean but
that's just my opinion of it what do you
think Briggs umm I agree with you I
actually think like so many Naruto
characters that just look extremely cool
the way they're drawn Wow one Pete on
the other hand is very like everything
is very unique and original and like
kind of weird in a way and like we were
talking about like senior pink
the guy who's wear that I've got a
picture of him here I love you guys
could see ya yo my man what about it
yeah yeah my name is English if you see
this character like what's the health
have a weird character is this guy
designing but a nice library a character
like the way it's drawn only matters so
much and the story of why he's wearing
that was actually like amazing see but
that's one thing that like I always
looked at one piece as a deterrent to
newer fans like aside from the legs
because they always say you know you
shouldn't judge a book by its cover but
everyone just look by it's cover
people you like one of the like if
you're looking at manga one of the first
things you're gonna look at obviously is
the artwork and if the artwork doesn't
look intriguing to you there are people
out there myself included sometimes that
might not even give it a chance now if
I'm recommended something and I'm not a
big fan of the art I'm someone who's
I'll give anything a shot at people tell
me it's good and I do feel like a story
should be able to stand on its own legs
as a story and with that merit more so
than the artwork but there are Hmong out
there that I have read that I'm not a
fan of with one of the major reasons
being the artwork like for example some
of you know that my favorite anime of
all time is fully Cooley I'm a die-hard
full equally fanboy and there are
actually two volumes that were published
by Tokyopop for fully Cooley it's a
manga that was made after the anime and
I think it is possibly the worst manga
I've ever read and clearly forgot about
that
yeah like I own the volumes I think they
look kind of cool you know because it's
got a nice little color to them and I'm
just such a fanboy like I just had to
have them but when I bought those
volumes I expected the artwork in the
Hmong cuz I had never I never even knew
it existed I saw a pop about eBay and I
just bought it without hesitation
I expected the artwork inside to look
like the scenes in the fooly cooly anime
where like they change it and it looks
like a market that's not the case at all
it has without a doubt the worst hearts
all I've ever seen and it detracts so
much because one of the amazing things
about fully quickly for example is how
it's all visually interesting and you
have all these different styles and this
amazing animation done by Gynexin
production i.g and stuff and there's
just other stories that I have read that
I just can't get into because the the
artwork is so poor in my opinion or I'm
just I just find it so distasteful that
is the distraction story and I just
can't get into it so it's just something
I thought throw out there like what
about hunter under for instance oh I
think the 100 hundred manga is very well
written
but it's also one of the most poorly
drawn and it is very exacting and I
would never recommend a hundred a manga
to anyone but that's just me like I know
there are people out there who would but
I would always hope like if anyone ever
asking about it I'd always tell them to
watch the anime because for one it has a
decent ending like there's a there's any
part where you can stop and be somewhat
satisfied whereas with the manga not
only do you have to suffer through
Takashi's artwork whether it's the the
clean up bridges or not there's just
some very very poorly drawn panels and
entire chapters in there um and then you
even if you do suffer through that
you're left with cliffhangers and the
possibility that you might not ever see
more of it or a tender years right yes
completely agree Lotus I just want to
piggyback that I'm really happy that you
brought that topic up about one piece
because that is one of the criticisms I
do hear about one piece besides its
length as we have noted is its art style
and as an artist I can appreciate the
exaggerations and how much skill Oda has
and creating all these funky characters
which he can back up with interesting
and in-depth analysis but at the same
token I feel like
Kishimoto that's one of the reasons why
Kishimoto
story has become so popular I think is
because the characters do look a little
more human it's a little more accessible
for most folks I think because as I was
a bookseller for seven years so I know
people how much people judge covers an
artwork instantaneously and they'll make
a split decision whether they're going
to pick that up but they're not going to
pick that up and I feel like that's kind
of one of the reasons one piece hasn't
become quite as popular here in the West
in comparison to Naruto is because of
the art style and I personally think
that's kind of a kind of a shame because
Oda is such an accomplished artist but I
think that's just how funny things work
out people like to see characters that
look a little more human we can relate
to them slightly better even if you gave
them a chance and realize that these
crazy characters Oda comes up with are
relatable it's like people are going to
make that split decision so in some
reasons like I'm happy to see the diver
and character and exaggeration Oda
creates but at the same time like I know
how much that's like affecting
negatively affecting its sales here in
America at least doesn't seem to bother
everyone in Japan kisses like what is a
best-selling manga of all time but over
here in the West it's pretty interesting
how there is that split between the art
style how art style is affecting
people's judgement I know it's
definitely something that's affected my
judgment because there's even a series
right now how many of you have read a
bit called twin starts by the way don't
don't ever watch the anime if you have
any interest in slo read the manga
please do so favor
um but yeah that is a manga that I
personally discovered in like late 2015
I was in a book civilian just hanging
out cuz I kind of like to go there and
just relax read new stuff and check out
the selections whatever and I saw two
instructors on the shelf Volume one and
I just thought that the cover this looks
so [ __ ] cool that I had to have it I
flipped through it I thought the art
would look incredible it looked like an
interesting enough story to me and just
off an impulse decision
I bought it there on the spot and I'm
not even someone who usually pays retail
price for manga because I usually like
to go to write stuff because they have
great deals I got a membership there so
that's usually my go-to spot but I just
thought that the artwork looks so
engaging and interesting and just
aesthetically pleasing to me that I
bought it right then and there so I know
that there's millions of other people
out there in the world who are just like
that where they're going to judge
something and they may or may not make
an impost decision on whether or not
they're going to pick up on something
simply because of the way it looks
especially with manga which is you know
so artwork base like it's so artwork
heavy like it plays a major role
it's nearly 50/50 with with how
important the story is yeah yeah really
good points here because I personally
really bad at visual art and miss art so
we're like definitely not on the same
page so I can kind of feel feel for the
manga cut that might some some do it
intentionally some might not like you
meant for the hunter under and they're
just not good at it I kind of feel bad
because like yeah I'm a writer like I've
write fiction I've published fiction so
in that sense I'm a book lover and I
didn't know miss art that you actually
worked as a bookseller here's that's
that's really cool uh but yeah I
personally suck at visual art so I'm uh
you know I'm a writer but I suck at
Ridgemont so I can definitely relate
because I would love to one day write on
manga but I would not be able to do
art I would have to hire someone to do
it for me but um in terms of some of the
comments and by the way simply Rose is
in Korea now our friends of the Rose and
she says it in Korea one piece is huge
as well that it's like everywhere you
can't go anywhere without seeing
something from one piece so apparently
in Korea just like in Japan one piece is
huge but we had some really interesting
comments from comments in the comments
now I might have lost about I think uh
where did I leave this give me give me a
second I'm taking time homie I'm envious
of all these people go into South Korea
may I simply rose I feel like she just
went there unless she's still over there
I've been seeing it feels like I've seen
so many people on YouTube and Twitter
lately who are traveling out of the
country whether they live in it's been a
lot of people from the Americas in UK
I've seen their like to all travel in
the Korea Japan I liked him I've never
been outside of the country and I'm just
so envious like must be nice like I've
never even less the east coast of the
United States let alone travel outside
the country Oh Liz I hope you do one day
it's great that's one of one of my
biggest dreams is to just travel and I
just haven't been able to do that I've
traveled you know a decent part half of
the country over on this side but I want
to go to other places like welcome to
the west coast I'd love to go to like
San Diego or LA or something for fun
that'd be great yeah I person have been
to Europe and Latin America but I've
been to Asia yet and I definitely want
to go to Japan Korea Philippines like
all those countries I would love to see
and will soon I'm sure but okay I found
my question it's from Knox Taku by the
way great YouTube rockstar please shout
out to him he says one piece has a world
of people with varied opinions but
Naruto has a big time main bad guy
complex so I think what he's saying here
is that Naruto is more black and white
whereas one piece is more nuanced in
terms of different opinions different
conflicts different ideas of bouncing
off each other so all you guys think
about that criticism I would disagree
I would say that Naruto definitely has
several points in the story where it is
kind of black and white and everyone
who's currently involved in the story at
that point they are very like my day
there's like one main villain but I
would feel like even towards the end of
NARS oh it's like the fourth great ninja
war there's a lot of conflict during and
before that where people don't agree
like getting the shinobi alliance
together and and it's finding a common
enemy was a very difficult thing for
them to do like during that whole five
Kage summit arc uh all of the villages
were in disagreement with each other and
they didn't like there was even one of
the villages I forget which I think it
was the su Chi cago who he admitted to
using the Akatsuki for his own personal
means and setting hiring them to do
missions for him which was very very
very frowned upon by some of the other
villages mainly being the leaf because
they look at the Akatsuki is such a
dangerous enemy so I would say that
there definitely are definitely villains
where everyone looks at them and goes ok
this is the bad guy we all get to team
up and then even though that does happen
again towards the end there are moments
where it's like okay you have to there
there's things I haven't beforehand in
order for you to reach that point where
people are in agreeance and deciding
this is a common enemy okay okay I would
say this is actually probably one of the
reasons why I prefer one piece because
the way I see it is in one piece you
have all these different kinds of traits
like you have the good the bad or the
evil will say you got your neutral your
chaotic good lawful evil that whole
spectrum whereas in Naruto even though
those things are present like I will
admit they're there they're way more
scarce especially towards the end of
Naruto Shippuden because at the very end
it mainly just becomes oh hey this is
the good side and this is the evil side
there's not really anything in between
like there's maybe a very small handful
of characters who still remain in their
own little world but there's not a whole
spectrum like there isn't one piece
constantly right like the whole nuance
is probably way more prominent one piece
and I can't speak on it personally but
I'll definitely give it to you just
awesome
principle I guess mmm-hmm I would agree
as well what would you say to that
masseur I would agree as well and I'd
not quite sure if this plays into just
how long and how much more development
one piece has gotten overall considering
where it is in its storytelling but yeah
agree that Naruto it has its moments
where there's definitely disagreement
and we're definitely getting multiple
perspectives on one dilemma but at the
end of the day everybody usually gets on
board and there's one main villain
usually um and everyone agrees you're
going to kick their butt they all agree
to a plan at the end of it so you still
start out with nuance but then it gets
pretty black-and-white when it comes
down to crunch time so not to say that's
not enjoyable because then you're
getting some really interesting battle
scenes and that's when the story can
really focus on the action but I think
I'd have to give it to one piece that it
just has a little more room to encompass
all the neutrals all the gray
perspectives
um throughout and I think it is due to
its length and how much it still has to
go you know I think another it's
probably fair to say that one piece has
better world-building than ours so
because even though there is world with
the world building in art so it's
probably not nearly as expensive as it
is one piece because you have so many
characters and slit early like all
across the globe and I don't know how
the one piece world works because it
seems like even things like gravity and
space and whatever else don't work the
same way as I do in real life as of
course it doesn't animate but it is
definitely different so I just feel like
there's probably more places to go to
because you have mainly the five great
villages in our so and even though we do
visit a map yeah right like you have you
have a defined map whereas you don't
have that one piece I don't think right
because that's like one of the
characters goals to make that map so
it's like you have places that you can
constantly discover and explore and I
think that's one of the reasons why you
come across so many characters I have
these varying opinions and it also has
to do with the fact that there's so many
unique characters in that world so
that's probably one of the biggest
reasons as to why you have that nuance
in one piece so more ambitious world
building with one piece yeah because
this is because one piece seems like one
of those theories where it was actually
started like one of the very few series
out there that it was started with the
thought in mind that this could go on
for a long time because it seems like
Monica and I don't know if that your
road I had any series out before one
piece this might be his only worker I
don't know um but so many Monica they
get into this business and they they
don't see you know
they don't think about we know what is
this who's going to be like in the next
10 years because they're just you know
usually happy and excited to have gotten
accepted get get published at all like
there's so many series out there like
Naruto and Dragonball for example like
they didn't expect it to get this
popular go on for this long they just
thought they were going to do a little
thing and it would be successful for a
while I move on to the next or maybe
even get canned and scrapped but one
piece seems like a series where it
started off in mind with the idea that
this could go on for a very long time
and I want it to go on for a very long
time which is the mindset that I don't
think a lot of manga have at the
beginning of their story but one piece
is like like I'm trying to say is one of
the series I think it started off
thinking okay I want this big wide world
and we're gonna explore as much of it as
possible
mm-hmm I don't completely agree that's
like kinda what I was saying at the
beginning I think it was designed to be
long running and it's one of the few
showings that like it kind of makes
sense to be long running oh my one my
one question to the one piece folks
would be because this story keeps going
on it's like you know that story usually
follows a trajectory you know you have a
you know set up conflict conclusion a
catharsis how do you follow a show that
keeps going but there's no end in sight
do you think that's good storytelling
any other at the end of the day if it
just keeps going going going and there's
no structure there's no catharsis
there's no conclusion see um I think
it's one thing all shonan's have like a
little bit of problem with cut is so
long but like we were saying earlier
what I like is we've been given this
information like somewhat recently
basically we've always known that we
have to get to the end of the grand line
type of thing but now we have
understanding where the grand line ends
and where the new world starts what they
have to do in turn in order to get the
one piece so it's like they have all
these smaller climaxes in between all
these smaller arcs but they're still
always that angle I mean now we
understand how they're going to get the
end goal so I think it's good
storytelling it's just a long journey I
feel like one piece also does have a
little bit of a problem with sometimes
repeating a couple things just because
you know it's so long some things are
bound to happen
the same way even if they're vastly
different whereas Naruto there wasn't
really too
repeats I would say but I also feel that
as long as the story's interesting and
new things are being brought up and
talked about and there's new conflicts
even if things are repeated as long as
there's something new about it I think
as long as you're enjoying it what's the
problem okay so you guys feel that one
piece does have interesting side stories
as they get to the main overarching
story so for that reason it still keeps
you interested yeah definitely part of
it okay sounds good sounds good now I
have a question for each side what is
the one thing that you feel that really
makes Naruto or one piece unique that
makes it better than other anime in your
opinion and not not even necessarily the
other one in this debate in particular
but just what makes it stand out you one
thing if you had to name one thing what
is it that really makes it a special
anime for you and miss art I think we
can start with you I have to say magical
ninja like what what could be cooler the
ninja with superpowers and I think
that's why it's had the series has had
such a mass appeal worldwide is because
magical ninjas is such a cool premise
I mean magical pirates is pretty cool
too but there's something about ninjas
we want to get into the ninja versus
pirate debate there's something that's
such rich territory for exploration when
it comes to ninja so I think that's like
the coolest factor to me about this
series is you get the supernatural you
get the magic and you get the action and
the subterfuge that comes with the topic
of ninja and I would I would definitely
agree with that and it's a lot like what
I was had in my mind of what I was gonna
say is that to me when I was younger I
just thought Naruto was just cool like
if I had to sum it up in one word
I thought Naruto was cool I thought it
was cool as [ __ ] I saw one piece back in
the day you know on four kids granted
the dub may have contributed to I don't
know I don't think I care to look like
that when I was younger but I never
thought one piece was cool I thought it
was really stupid and lame now granted
this is my opinion back then I'm grown
more mature now given a chain
I wouldn't say that it's trash or
anything like that I'm just not a fan
but like I I'm not a fan of pirates I
don't think pirates are like a cool
thing like they don't interest me
I thought Luffy was weird being able to
stretch yourself like that and I think
there's other people out there who would
be like-minded and I think it's a common
thing around the world that people think
ninjas are just really cool they're
really interesting I think every little
girl and boy has at one point pretended
to be a ninja or done some ninja like
things so it's like okay they see Naruto
this series that's full of ninjas and
they have all these cool crazy powers
it's like yo that's so dope I want to be
a ninja like Naruto and I think that's
one of the reasons why I gravitated
towards the series so much why so many
of the people around the world and
especially in the u.s. do and that's
another thing like especially in the
u.s. because we here we we see something
like ninjas which is something that
comes from Asia it's a foreign concept
to us and for us that's like unique
that's like interesting it's engaging we
want to see more that we want explore
them like that because I'm someone who
believes that since America is like such
this like melting pot like we want to
take from as many places as possible and
pirates don't seem like something that's
like you can pinpoint I could be wrong
on this but like you know pinpoint like
okay pirates came from this country and
so I want to explore more of that was
like okay ninjas are from Asia and I
want to explore more about Asia because
it seems like a really cool place and
this is something this is how I see this
is how I feel
oh definitely American generals had a
love affair with Japanese culture
specifically exactly yeah yeah and and I
know Naruto for sure builds a lot on
Japanese tradition and culture and
obviously adds supernatural abilities
things like that but it is rooted more
so than one piece in that yea deeply in
the mythology yeah
however I would say that to me ninjas
and pirates are both quite cool they're
outlaws they're you know strong fighters
they're feared I think both of them are
very cool and I you know I just thought
of this while we were having the
discussion but yeah both very cool
concepts to me and I know my brother
goes and thinks pirates are super cool
and always did always loved pirates and
reading about them as much so I have to
say that I think load is that both are
very cool constant I mean yeah it's each
your own I just know that me as a person
I I never thought pirates were cool like
the Pirates of the Caribbean movies like
I've never
watch any of those gonna just don't
interest me I'm like no I don't care
about Jack spell you know okay boss Jack
Sparrow a really cool first let me great
goes not hell from there I mean Johnny
Depp's an awesome guys an amazing actor
I like him a lot but I just don't care
to see him in on a boat in the middle yo
but if he dresses up as a ninja let me
know Oh next roll man ninjas of the
southern in body they go
but um okay so we got the scoop from
Lotus and Miss art now to do spooky what
is the one thing that in one piece that
really stands out to you I think the
main thing in one piece that stands out
to me is definitely the world because in
the one piece world there's always
something new going on like the rules
are always being established and in the
one piece world there's just so many
different things that all come together
like obviously the main focus is
definitely the pirate aspect of it but
you also have all these different races
of people like you have the fish men the
long leg tribe and the whatever you got
the Giants you have the Marines even
though they're not really a race but
just another faction you have all these
different pirate crews that even though
they're all pirates they don't always
see eye to eye like like I said you have
your different kinds of you good your
neutral all that kind of stuff you have
your scientist there's like weapons of
mass destructions recently there was
even a ninja there was even a ninja in
one piece every name I got a google it I
think it's right so pretty sure it's
Rhys oh it was a I think it's pretty uh
I'm pretty sure it's just a nod to
Kishimoto to be honest but like they're
getting to the whole samurai aspect like
they're going to be going to the Wan Oh
which is basically where all the samurai
are soon so like there's always
something new in one piece it's not just
about pirates that's an
interesting-looking good job tell you
something yeah the Luffy screw had the
same reaction they were so excited to
see a ninja because you know everyone
loves lindros but then they're like what
you're a ninja just a little bit meta
there for
the folks at one-piece ah Briggs what
what stands up to you see I definitely
do with a 2spooky I almost called you by
your name there for a second Oh Oh
what's the call the one thing I love is
like for example Marines can be very
good at all about justice while Marines
at the same time can be so corrupt and
pirates could be absolute scum of the
earth or they could be good genuine
people that are just fighting for what
they believe in so it's kind of like the
whole like like difference between good
bad and like corruption and stuff that
too foofy was talking about but for me
the one thing that's like drives the
show for me is a hundred percent the
characters I can never choose like who's
my favorite character in one piece it's
leaving by Sanji right now but I go back
and forth i flip-flop so much and it's
so hard for me to narrow down like when
I start naming my favorite characters it
goes on for dozens of characters well I
absolutely like I've been ripping on
Naruto or like talking bad about notch I
wanna let anyone know I actually am a
fan of Naruto it just like my Cu series
I kind of go downhill it hurts but I
love so much that was so warm to my
heart one of the child I give you a
little bit mean towards it but like I
like characters in Naruto I like a lot
of characters in Naruto but just in one
piece just so many characters from
villains that even villains eyes love so
much I like Marines and stuff it's so
hard for me to choose so it's characters
deftly drive the show for me interesting
very interesting because you're saying
that the fact that you can't even choose
your favorite character you switch just
shows how good the characters are and
how there's a wide variety of good
characters right well the variety is
huge like I love I like characters and
Marines like I'm just looking forward
from look like come back and do some
battles see I think that's another thing
that one piece has on the side when it
comes to its length is like if you're
that if you are someone who's already
invested into the story like you get
really attached these characters you've
grown to love them you know so much
about them and you can say the same for
Renard so for some of the characters but
not all of them like like one piece
might at the edge of ledges because
again they have so many more but um yeah
cuz I have one thing that I will say is
that someone who's new to it though cuz
this is something that I thought of
right when you start talking about how
much you love the care you can't take a
favorite is that for what I read of one
piece I didn't have a favorite character
because I just didn't care about any of
them like
just I was only one who I thought was
like he's kind of interesting was a
Robin because she did have a interesting
backstory that I gave her that like when
it comes to like uh what's his name
who's up I was like okay this [ __ ] is
annoying get him out of my face he's
gotta go yeah I gotta end of the guy
Zhora I was like oh cool dude with
swords and then he turned out to be kind
of boring me right now dude you know
doing much I thought he was gonna be
really cool it probably is now but at
the time I didn't really care about him
but uh I think that is something that
with you're someone who has been
invested into the story for a while but
you've read the hundreds of chapters
where you've seen the hundreds of
episodes that are out is that a you have
so many characters to choose from that
you become so invested in and grown to
know and love so that's that's probably
something that keeps a lot of people who
are still missing into series around and
continue to be invested because they
slept with these characters for so long
man there's a lot of you know you guys
being nice to each other in this Rand
cafe like there's no insults there's no
you're massaging let me knock some of
that it's man this is nothing like our
debate over on Tony's channel yeah I
know huh
Tony's we went at it we were just like
RAM versus Emilia bro oh man you want
any territory yeah I'm trying to keep
the civil because I already know you
know I'm not gonna name no names point
no elbows no fingers nothing but uh just
some really sensitive fans out there you
know and uh firsthand the negativity
that can come when you uh start talking
down to somebody else's series and I'm
not trying to say that one piece is a
garbage series it may or may not be I'm
just saying I'm not a fan you know yeah
yeah and uh in terms of sensitive
fanboys I can definitely tell you that
the RAM fanboys are quite sensitive or
as Briggs likes to call her blue ram the
ram I feel like I don't know I don't
know who you're talking about to be
honest Oh blue Ram no yeah it's true
tawny and such for for uh his RAM
fanboying
but um my last question for you guys and
Luna actually mentioned this in the chat
shout out to Luna and I've actually
wanted to ask this anyways as to me like
someone like me
or anyone
hasn't given either of these anime a
chance what would you say to actually
get me to give this enemy a chance how
would you get me into it whether it's
your friend well there's just someone on
the Internet
how would you get me into it especially
in terms of both our long anime or a
manga series both are quite a commitment
so what would you say to me or someone
like me simple get me simple in theory
all I got to do I pull up one clip from
the Lee versus Gaara fight I have you
watched that ask if you want more the
answer is of course going to be yes and
that's already excellent I would just
say again my same argument magical
ninjas like that that top of the loan
should sell it with awesome battles true
I feel like I feel like that's a pretty
good elevator pitch straight into the
full Dalek point right there I can't
nothing you could do to argue with a
magical ninja right there yeah magical
ninjas and magical ninjas having really
badass fights so I mean good points here
one piece guys and you have a bit of a
harder job because of how long the anime
hit how big a commitment it is how do
you get someone who's not into it to
actually be into it how do you get
someone like Tony to stop just mocking
you screaming yo yo yo yo and actually
give it a chance
um so well like I'm recommending it to
you I think I have a little bit of an
advantage I know what you like kind of
like a little bit now if you're not a
like you're not really about like
cry-baby characters or anything like
that so I like to say Luffy is the type
of guy who is just like [ __ ] you I don't
care I'm doing I can do whatever I want
whatever I believe in I'm gonna do it I
can defy the odds like he burnt down the
world government flag and wage war with
the world just like for one friend and I
was kind of savage yeah like he's like I
don't give a [ __ ] about that go on
against every pirate ever like oh he was
on the phone with uh they have phones
apparently you know my snail things on
the phone with this think that one of
the biggest pirates ever anything yeah
and they were like huge they were
threatening people he like he's he's
like I'm coming after you type of thing
and like you're literally waging war
people who
like well like anyone they come cause
what they like massacres I hear
something here how do you think he's
like I think that's a badass character
something you can really like you would
be into so it's like worth the
commitment even if a little bit to get
into it you know you do know me well you
do know me well because and I've been
thinking about this because I tend to
dislike generic battle shonan's but it
mostly seems to be certain ones like my
hero academia or like Eureka Seven where
the character is a crybaby and also
where the character doesn't seem to have
a goal other than being the best he can
be kind of for himself
I don't you you uh are you not a fan of
my hero no I'm not at all okay that's
cool just asking my brother is I'm not
at all but to me I feel like the shown
in the battle showing that I really do
like is one there's a something else at
stake so with something like um in
Gurren Lagann you're saving the universe
or fighting against injustice or saving
our kingdom like in seven deadly sins
like to me that is seems to be what kind
of other and the crybaby aspect what
drives me is a kind of like a higher
purpose rather than just I want to be
the best me I can be I want to be the
you know the best hero I can be for
myself or to prove myself I feel like I
need more than that and that's why I
feel like I kind of grew out of Dragon
Ball Z as well because they went from
saving the world to let's have
tournaments to see you stronger and [ __ ]
like that
so yeah that's something I've been
thinking about in terms of battle Shonen
and that what speaks to me I guess is
that kind of like having a higher
purpose than just yourself well you
should like Naruto then you should get
Naruto a chance because that's
ultimately what the final battle the
main battle is focused on is saving the
world the entire world if not other
dimensions yes it and I actually
mother's basement made a video where he
argued that um Naruto was more like well
he for clickbait he called it communism
but he said artists for you community
oriented and collective whereas my hero
academia is more individualistic and
kind of like similar to capitalism kind
of every man for himself
but the video is problematic he
stretched that comparison completely you
can I can dis come it's a cultural thing
too because uh Japan is more of like
culturally is more about cooperation and
here in the West where my hero academia
is based on Western uh archetypes for
comics I mean that that makes sense so
yeah but he stretches the comparison
there's a lot of counterpoise that can
be made that he doesn't address so yeah
I have issues with a lot of his videos
he's very like I think there is an
interesting video there to be made but
he probably just didn't do it as well as
it could have been done from my
understanding how you're approaching it
boisterous he's boys just he likes to
get in your face like oh look at this
argument but then it's like men you come
off as pretentious but you don't
actually make that point uh and or you
purposely you know skew it in a certain
way just to make it more appealing it to
click on but that's just my bit of my
rant about battle Shonen and other stuff
too spooky I think you installment heard
from you and to why how to get someone
into one piece who doesn't want to make
the commitment doesn't want to get a
chance hey you can probably find it
somewhere in one piece no matter what it
is like what it is that's probably said
yeah probably carry ok all territory is
gonna be covered exactly oh it's so long
we've got your slice of life we got your
battle showing it we got your mecca's we
got everything everyone down I'm not
even kidding you want to Mecca battle
you'll get one sure you want interests
are there you want samurai there there
you won't you want some sports anime you
want some swimming you want to get
mermaid we got of all it's all marry
everything you are you everything there
everything is 300 chapters you know
they're 400 chapters in and you're I
promise you I'm getting into one piece
if they introduce Keijo as a one piece
crossover I will I then I might have to
catch up to one pieces my ass I'll read
those 700 chapters if they introduce
Cajun one piece forward I'm a Cade row
man myself
it's a good show most underrated show of
the show that season yeah absolutely
hilarious better than yours
but yeah I don't think I have any more
questions I thought this is a really
good debate you both sides made really
good points both sides agree with each
other on certain things which you know
surprised me a bit we didn't rent as
much but I feel like both sides have
married and I got your dog one piece is
ugly as [ __ ] if you want see some cool
ass [ __ ] Beauregard so right now
right now right now don't waste your
time reading 800 chapters of a story
that's never gonna end
go recent Naruto you'll love yourself
you love me what's like we'll talk later
I cool
who shot breathe why is that fired you
know before we finish this up do you
guys mind if I bring one more argument
to you just because I haven't been able
to actually ask some hardcore Naruto
fans what they think about this go ahead
go ahead
okay so I feel like the second half of
Naruto Shippuden like after after pain
has been defeated
I think that Naruto Shippuden at that
point has the worst villain problem of
all time like you like before anything I
think that moderate is probably one of
the most badass villains of all time
right that's my boy all right I'm gonna
drizzle the absolute worst motivation
for what he does I read like I had to
confirm this with myself so I read like
the last 100 chapters of Shippuden not
too long ago but basically moderates
whole reason for wanting the infinite
tsukiyomi to just screw everyone over
was because he was a sore loser that's
it
because he lost takashi rama he wanted
to [ __ ] everyone over it but really say
that was his motivation I think that's
more of his motivation for like leaving
the village well I think his whole thing
for wanting to do the infinite tsukiyomi
is just so that he gets his way and he
can bring peace of the world in the way
that he saw fit and it is him being a
sore loser but I don't think that's like
the motivation behind it he's not doing
this like is he's not doing this because
he lost he's doing this because this is
something that he would have done anyway
so it's like he said he specifically
said to Obito that no matter what
there's always going to be winners and
losers this person
him going hey I'm a loser I'm salty
about it let's let's start a war well
you see trouble withi yeah this is the
confusion is that monitors character is
rigidly introduced way back in the day
it was as the loser to hoshi Dhamma and
of course that definitely influenced his
direction but yet the many many many
decades happened after that fight and
whether or not monitor believes this is
an off like shooting off of the fact
that he lost the whole reason he wants
to do the infinite tsukuyomi does have
more ties that go beyond that battle
because if you watch your pay attention
to a lot of his backstory you'll notice
that he originally uh grew up when the
ninja world was at its worst where they
were literally sending out child
soldiers like him and his brothers were
like below the age of ten and being
forced to go out and fight battles and
he literally lost all of his brothers
and his entire family to violence and
all dis destruction is really ugly
terrible history so I think that is a
really big element that comes into play
of why he doesn't want to see war
anymore he doesn't want to see child
soldiers he doesn't want to see these
huge dynamic battles anymore he just
wants everything to settle he's had too
many decades of war and strife and
that's why he wants to infinite
tsukuyomi just so everything is a
neutral gray he can make sure everything
just stays happy and normal the end so I
think that's really his underlying
motivation it's just that he's sick and
tired of all these wars he's really good
at wars and he makes an excellent
villain so it's kind of ironic but to me
that's where his main motivation is it
comes from a deeper place of loss that
yes he is a loser he lost his entire
family
he's lost many battles and now he just
wants to make the world and his mind win
by never having to have war again for
pain again I'm not saying that's not
true because all that definitely did
happen but he never brought that up to
Obito as any part of his reasoning for
wanting
do this like after everyone like
basically what I'm trying to say is he
and hoshi rama they started the hidden
leaf village so they already
accomplished all of that and obviously
things happened which pushed him out and
he was upset about that as well but i
don't think he would want to start a war
just because he wasn't accepted in the
village and i think it goes beyond that
because they started the village and i
thought that was going to be you know
the solution all right all the clans are
going to come together and we're gonna
have peace but eglee martin estates this
- i'm not sure when but basically the
village system turned out to be terrible
because then the villages just started
to go to war with each other went from
clans small clans so now oh great now
everybody's grouped together and war is
just escalating so ant you have to
remember when he's speaking the Obito
he's also manipulating Obito a very
young Obito so i think he says a lot of
things - in that particular conversation
he shares a lot of his philosophies that
he thinks they're going to best touch on
Obito and turn him to his side so i
don't think you get the full picture of
his motivations just from that one
conversation or multiple conversations
with Obito some that definitely agree on
and I just want to state that like he
grew up in this time of war where all he
knew as a way of life was that it's
survival of the fittest like the strong
survive and the weak die and so that's
that's kind of like what he's grown to
know was that okay if I want to rule the
world if I want to if I want to make the
world if I want to shape it in the way
that I see fit and is the right way I
have to do it by being the strongest and
so I wouldn't say that he's a pacifist
but he is similar to Itachi in a lot of
ways where he doesn't want to fight but
I think moderate solution to everything
is to have one final fight that's the
end of all fights the one last war that
is the end of all wars and that's kind
of what I think his his goal and vision
was it wasn't to like okay I'm a sore
loser so this is the way I'm going to do
it's like okay I see all this corruption
in the world and this is the only way I
see fit to put an end to all of it so
it's kind of like him just making
himself the common enemy and then uh
manipulating the entire world to shape
it in a way that he thinks is the
solution to everything honestly because
he's a sore loser
he thinks that's the only way because
all he's known all his life is uh power
by destruction well that that's really
interesting because now you reminding me
of Lelouch from code I know you're gonna
say it but I do I you got me interested
but yeah that's that's a comparison that
I've made before and I've talked about
it in like other videos or with other
people but I wouldn't really call a
moderate quite deluge he has definitely
some loose like qualities but I think
Sasuke and I brought this up cuz I
remember when I read that chapter and he
said he want to become Hokage and kind
of get off topic here but I want to talk
about it now when Sasuke is talking
about how he wants to become Hokage I
was like okay the plan that he gave was
exactly like the plan Lelouch gives
where Sasuke wanted to become Hokage so
he's a common enemy of the world
everyone wants to take him down but with
that way he brings everyone else
together just to oppose him and I
thought that was like a really great
idea because that's one of the things
that I loved about Code Geass was like I
like Lelouch did it like he it solved
all the world's problems he he won in a
way like he lost but he won like he he
achieved its goal so when Sasuke said
that I was like yo he's got the right
idea and I think moderate had like a
similar mindset that wasn't necessarily
like you not uniting everyone just uh by
opposing him but that's kind of like a
byproduct of it yeah and mob king said
in the chad miss Hart got it right
perfect explanation and yeah I thought
both of you that a great job addressing
Spooky's valid point I think you did a
great job here so excellent talk about
carga she's a [ __ ] yelling you win that
argument yeah yeah however however I
think we're gonna have to start slowly
wrapping this up in terms of who won
which anime wins I want you guys in the
chat to let me know what you think
however I will challenge you to actually
say why so if you think Naruto's feel
better say Y if you think one piece is
better say why don't just say the other
one is trash and same thing goes for the
comments for those of you who are not
watching live watching after the fact I
want to know what you think about the
debate and also about which anime like
more but then give me a good reason why
and before we wrap it up I just want to
go back to everyone again as so you can
say who you are and what you do and miss
Hart we'll start with you again since
you're the new kid on the block I'm the
new kid on the block well thank you once
again for invite
me too this anime rant I don't think we
ranted a lot but it was fun to debate
yeah this is a really fun debate so
thank you for inviting me to it and I
look forward to more in Grand cafes in
the future but yes my name is miss art
spelled mi SS AR T you can find me on
the youtubes if you like Naruto
definitely check out my channel I have
started doing boruto reviews the next
generation or if you want to check out
my backlog of Naruto manga and anime
reviews they are all there so yeah if
you're down with Naruto come check out
my channel you might be down with me too
you can also find me on Twitter at artsy
ali-a RTS I ll I so thank you again it
was fun guys thank you for joining us
and I like that if you're down with
Naruto then you're down with me I like
that like that ah Briggs from old anime
tell us who you are and what you do for
those who don't already know you and I
think everyone does but go ahead hello
hello I am Briggs from all the anime I
make FAQ videos interesting things you
wouldn't already know about characters
in series I also like to explain them
some stuff Lou recently did some cool
concept like one for all from my hero
academia and cool stuff like that I'm
actually a two subscribers away from ten
thousand if any oh yeah the old it's
time to get the bottles poppin what is
champagne at the top if you don't
subscribe if you're not subscribe to
British guys subscribe right now because
we can have him reach 10,000 on rent
cafe live hell that would be brick you
will remember it rent cafe forever and
my pretty face forever because of that
so yeah that would be really cool and
again everyone's link is in the
description miss art bricks too spooky
and Lotus lotus let's go to you who are
you and what do you do with lotus
Telesca and legend the kid who never
knows best you could find me over on my
channel the nerd cornered corner where I
like to do manga hold discussions on
manga manga tags I does anime reviews in
the past might be bringing those back
the pen and knowledge I think catches my
interest kind of inviting my time
because I want to review board so but I
want to get past this kind of like slice
of life
old days villain of the week type part
that way in right now and seeing where
it goes after we start reaching content
that wasn't covered in like the anime
manga or the animated movie rather but
uh yeah anime reviews discussions manga
tags discussions hall videos that videos
gaming content recently mostly anime
gaming but I might be introducing other
fighting games because the anime games
that do play usually fighting games like
the Naruto storm series and we'll be
playing shinobi Stryker whenever that
comes out and then I've been playing a
lot of xenoverse too you might see it
just as too soon Tekken 7 so well yeah
if you like anime manga and fighting
games you should go check out my channel
cuz it's probably the greatest channel
on earth yeah
and he's a very violent man so the games
he plays I don't have a lot of fighting
because he's not fighting he loves Dutch
shots fired you know [ __ ] one piece all
that stuff you got it Lotus nerdcore
nerd corner user it's also got some
great music in the background of all my
videos a lot of anime inspired music
that's where the nerd corner of my name
comes from by the way a lot of people
don't know that nerdcore by the way for
those who don't know is like a type of
it's a genre of music which is liked by
nerds for nerds and so it's kind of one
of the aspects that I incorporated to a
lot of my videos work really all of my
videos that a lot of the music you'll
hear in the background is oftentimes a
remix of an anime song like an opening
or a background song or something like
this so I don't know too many people who
have ever caught up on that but it's
something that I take pride in so yeah
yeah nice yeah I didn't know that way on
there music I'm all down for that for
sure Thank You Lotus and last but not
least too spooky a young youtuber you
guys might have heard of I know some of
you say in the chat that you're his
biggest fans like Natsu fired up so -
spooky who are you and what do you do
dah well hello there I'm not too spooky
I make video about videos about anime
and other stuff that I like there mainly
fact videos and toptenz and other stuff
like that and just so people don't get
the wrong idea I just want to say that I
am a huge fan of both Naruto and one
piece just so you're aware I'm not
bashing Naruto because I don't like it
or anything so if you like Naruto and
one piece uh feel free to stop on by
because you can find content on both
over there and thank you very much
2spooky link in the description and i
just want to say right now that old
anime is at ten thousand and one
subscribe
Thank You care boy welcome to the five
figures five digit or some antigens yeah
that should be five yep I'm the only one
in the four digit Club now interesting
yeah but you're getting five digits baby
congratulations ex ex-gf a alive you did
it live you'll never forget me now whoo
I feel like I feel like now we're in
this together
bro just always been oh yeah I also want
to throw out there by the way that
Naruto is not it like I'm not someone
who believes it's like one of the
greatest series ever or when I say that
I mean like I don't think it's like the
number one anime of all time like I said
before I'm a fully cool B fanboy I like
Naruto a lot but I can acknowledge his
flaws that's why I gave a lot of my
points to the 1p site when I brought up
legitimate arguments and points that I
thought you know one piece actually does
better than art so so just throwing it
out there I wanted I don't want to get
the wrong idea intelligent people I did
not have I didn't have double for anime
I'm here for a reason you know I am
representing Naruto that would have been
a you know love affair but you know we
had some reasonable intelligent people
and a great discussion great discussion
thank you everyone in the chat who came
and participated I see you guys are
saying what you thought about the debate
everyone checked it out if you're
interested and let leave your feedback
in the comments as well once the video
is uploaded because then the comments
that you leave are actually going to
stay there chat doesn't stay thank you
to my lovely guests 2spooky and Briggs
from all the anime on the one piece side
and Lotus and Miss art on the Naruto
side pleasure chatting with you guys and
lady yeah thank you for having us today
thank you
Asli [ __ ] my pleasure
and we'll do this something similar
again sometime soon I'm sure but until
next time see us space cowboys bang
should